Luke dominate here at the outdoor boys
YouTube channel today we're going to
show you how to survive one of the most
common emergency situations that you are
likely to face welcome to our three-man
solo Survival extravaganza
now we have shown you a lot of survival
videos we have shown you 14 ways to
start a fire without matches me and Nate
built a shelter in the winter time using
only logs and then slept in it but today
we're gonna show you a survival
situation so common that most of you
will face it at some point in your life
I'm gonna show you what to do when
you've locked yourself out of your house
but you're too embarrassed to tell your
wife that you forgot your keys again in
all survival situations being prepared
is key having the right tools can mean
the difference between life and death
and this situation is no different right
here on this deck we have everything we
need
prepared and hidden for just such an
emergency the key is to make sure that
your wife doesn't know that you're
prepared to forget your keys again all
right Tommy show them the kit yeah here
we go
we've got bed rolls and supplies for
each of the boys yep these bed rolls are
super convenient and there's something
you can prepare in advance and hide them
away for just such an emergency hammocks
pillows blankets small children these
are all great things to put inside your
bed roll
there we go what do you got Oh what is
that a hammock is this a hammock for
little kids they're not very deep
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I thought these kids hammocks online for
like 19 bucks but I am not loving them
it's fun but it's so small it's too
small for you Tommy and you're in you're
only six Nathan's only four and I think
it's 2-2 they're too small for him
they're not deep enough
so they roll out really easy for I think
they'd fit for Jacob but he's too young
to be left alone in the hammock the
bigger hammocks are nicer not only
because you won't fall out but they'll
give you more room you can just go like
this and keep the bugs out and on when
you get cold you can do that to warm up
so Jacob gets the pop-up tent and the
two older boys get the hammocks but I'm
gonna demonstrate how to make a shelter
using only materials I can find locally
in December time bugs can be a real
problem so there's a couple solutions
you can rub yourself in a mixture of
pine tar and mud to help keep the bugs
off or you can get a high powered
electrical fan and simply blow that on
yourself to keep the bugs away
I personally prefer the fan method
that's good
hi Jake overcoming psychological
hardships is just as important as
overcoming the elements and hunger and
to do that we're using the Roku app on
my phone to watch TV through the
living-room window oh you want to watch
the zombie trapping one is the Axl show
better than the outdoor boy's YouTube
channel oh man you know Jacobs about one
years old and this hammock about the
right size for him but he's so little I
don't trust him in this thing without me
really close cuz if he sits up he's
gonna just keel over but he seems to
enjoy it
[Music]
now guys I'm gonna show you how you can
find food using only basic tools that
you might find in your pockets no
specialty snares or bows and arrows or
anything this is really basic hunter
gathering uh yeah I'd like to order for
delivery well it also ain't gonna coupon
for a free sweet-and-sour chicken I'm
sorry I should have mentioned that
earlier there we go ah students you like
this camping trip yep
are we surviving bear Griz wasn't eat
this good if he had all the urine in the
world this is good food right here Oh
spicy mustard
here's our Jacob sleeping bag
there we go yeah
in addition to demonstrating our awesome
survival skills this hyper-realistic
survival situation is also going to give
me a chance to try out some of my new
flashlights and other gadgets
unfortunately the Sun is setting after
the kids bedtime nowadays so we're gonna
try to keep them up just a little bit
it's past your bedtime buddy get your
jammies oh come on buddy let me help you
get the wrapper off it tastes much
better that way let me show you guys
some of my lights I've got a
rechargeable lantern here it's got a
couple different settings alright works
pretty darn good put that right there
get the boys some light and I've got
this rechargeable headlight there's only
like ten bucks
works pretty well like it really light
easy on the head and it's rechargeable
that's our frog hunting light this thing
goes out there ways here's a little
flashlight I got it's a palm-sized thing
it's the DN 70 from Emaline it's got a
little screen on it tells you your
voltage and your setting so I got 4.11
volts or and 20 lumens and 300 lumens
thousand lumens 2500 lumens and then I
can go turbo mode at 3,800 lumens I'll
put a link in the description of these
different flashlights this one's
expensive it's about a hundred bucks
this is really cheap that little spot
light there was pretty affordable like
thirty bucks I think so found out a
variety of price ranges all right like
this you're so out of bed
so we finally got them all to bed we'll
see if they stay that way it could be a
long night
well now that it's properly dark I want
to test out my little D and seventy palm
light here let's turn this thing on
okay that's what is that 20 lumens there
I can barely see that bush that's 300
lumens there you go that's a thousand
lumens there we go 2500 lumens and then
turbo mode 3,800 lumens
look at that that is bright thing is
powerful heats up pretty quick too like
a hand warmer
why don't I waking up the boy so I'm
going to turn this thing off I'll see
you guys in the morning
good morning Jacob the last of the food
eat it well you have a fine capacity for
the enjoyment of life that's not a
fortune that's an observation see I I
get him all their nice little hammocks
and tents and everything they all end up
dog piling on top of me no matter where
I put him well this was just kind of
something fun to do with my boys on a
weekday but I did have some ulterior
motives one I wanted to get Jacob used
to camping he's never been camping
before I want to take him out more now
that he's you know getting a little bit
older but gotta kind of ease him into it
get him used to sleeping outside of his
bed and sleeping in that little tent but
there's also another great reason we're
going to do a lot of traveling this
summer we're gonna be probably gone for
like three weeks in the UK and we're
gonna be in various hotels and
and we can bring that little pop-up tent
and put him in it so we can get him used
to sleeping in his pop-up tent we can
pretty much take him anywhere and he'll
sleep and it's a great way to sleep
train your kids but I better go take a
shower and get shaved I got to get to
court this morning so I will see you
guys later but thanks for watching and
we hope you enjoyed this video if you
want to see more great videos from the
outdoor boys YouTube channel don't
forget to click Subscribe we put out new
videos every Saturday morning if you
like this video don't forget to check
out the outdoor boys youtube channel
where we have hundreds of videos just
like this and don't forget to click
subscribe so you can see other great
videos every Saturday morning and hit
that Bell button so you'll get
notifications thanks for watching